let's go next to our caller from the
eight one six area code who's calling
today from eight one six
hey David uh this is jazz from Kansas
City Missouri hey jazz what's going on
so I was calling to ask you about how
you're voting in November okay
specifically on a ballot measure it
looks like Massachusetts will probably
have rank-choice voting on the ballot
will you be voting for it I've not seen
the language of it I actually didn't I
need to get schooled up on what's on the
ballot in in November so the answer is
depending on how it is written I very
well may and I we've I've done a lot of
interviews and segments on a number of
different voting systems there's the the
sort of a standard configuration of
rank-choice voting there is single
transferable vote there's a bunch of
different configurations and I like a
lot of them some of them are less than
perfectly structured and so I I need to
look at how it's written but that is
certainly something I would consider
voting for until I actually see the text
of the initiative it I wouldn't want to
say for sure uh actually Maine has
Instant Runoff voting and I'm pretty
sure that's what Massachusetts is
proposing and it's the it seems like the
easiest to implement system with given
our current constitutional structure but
yeah that's another consideration which
is sometimes the best system is more
complex constitutionally to implement
and you also don't want to let the
perfect become the enemy of the good as
someone someone once said I don't know
who yeah yeah well first-past-the-post
is arguably the worst right but do you
think progressives should focus on
electoral reform like on ballot
initiatives such as the main one and the
massachusetts absolutely so what for for
several years now one of the frame the
framework i've been prioritizing is
need to fix how politics is financed and
we need to fix how we vote and this can
include getting rid of
first-past-the-post this can include
getting away from the electoral college
system so yeah it's like if you care
about education or abortion or climate
or whatever to really make progress on
these issues you've got to fix some of
the structural problems that we have
health care I would consider one of
those structural problems in the sense
that if you are stuck at a job merely to
avoid losing health insurance it's going
to be difficult to be an activist for
what you care about so absolutely this
should be a priority for progressives
okay and one last question if your mind
sure um since Maine has rank-choice
voting now and they're gonna be voting
in 2020 but the rank-choice voting the
Instant Runoff how would you feel about
progressives in Maine putting Lisa
Savage the Green Party candidate as
their number one and the race against
Susan Collins I know nothing about her
so I would have to know I mean I get the
question is more of a mathematical
question you can vote for the Green
Party candidate without helping Susan
Collins if you have a system other than
first-past-the-post but but even still
given that I know nothing about her it
wouldn't be appropriate for me to say
yes do it because who know I just don't
know enough about her right right I was
more so just asking generally if under a
Instant Runoff system you think that
voting Green Party as number one would
be a good idea only if you support the
Green Party what I could the statement
that I can say more generally is with
such a system you can vote for the
person you most agree with without fear
that you may be helping the person
you're most opposed to that would be how
I would generalize the rule alright yeah
cool all right my friend thank you very
much for the phone call appreciate
hearing from you